[music]
>> Anyone born in the field of dawa, I
requested my parent that I would give
half time for dawa, half time for
medicine.
And because we had clinics and
consultation past my
MBBS, dropped my plans of doing PG
post-graduation.
Dawa is important. But as time went on,
hardly a few months,
I met
Dr. Isra Ahmed. Dr. Isra Ahmed also is a
person who has been an inspiration to
me. And if those of you who do not know
Dr. Isra Ahmed,
may Allah grant him Jannah.
He hailed from Lahore, Pakistan, and was
a medical doctor.
And as my passion was meeting scholars
and doers from different parts of the
world, going, interacting,
so when I reached Pakistan,
in Lahore, he said, "Beta, son,
what is the purpose of yours to come to
Pakistan?" So I said, "I've come to
visit Islamic organizations."
He said, "You will find many Islamic
organizations in Pakistan, but you will
not find Islam."
He told me
that what is your intention? I said,
"I'll do 50/50.
50% dawa, 50% medicine, 1991."
He told me, "Son,
I'm a medical doctor, MBBS. For 7 years,
I practiced,
and I tried to do both.
I had to choose between one. If you have
to specialize, you have to specialize in
one."
At that moment, I decided that
and realizing from Sheikh Ahmed Deedat,
the verse of the Quran, I started my
talk with Surah Fussilat, chapter 41,
verse number 33, where Allah says, "Who
is better in speech than one who invites
to the way of their Lord, works
righteousness, and says that I'm
Muslim?" Who is better in speech than
one who invites to the way of their
Lord, works righteousness, and says that
I'm Muslim.
I chose to become a doctor not because
my father was a doctor, but because I
thought at that time that doctor is the
best profession in the world, serving
humanity, serving the ummah at large.
Yes, it's also a lucrative profession in
terms of worldly things, and in terms of
society, it gives you the maximum
social status. And that time, it will
have
Being inspired by Sheikh Ahmed Deedat
and getting advice from Dr. Isra Ahmed,
I decided I have to choose between the
two if I have to specialize.
And
I chose to be
a full-time da'ee.
And I told my parents that
I want to leave this profession,
and I want to be a full-time da'ee. And
my parents said, "I don't understand
him."
No problem.
And alhamdulillah, then I got involved
in the field of dawa.
And Allah's help was there.
When we started
the Islamic Research Foundation, before
that, when Sheikh Deedat came to me in
1988 to Bombay, he gave us a full set of
his videos. So we made copies and gave
it to our video cassette library, that
give it for free distribution, for free
hire, and get it back.
Free hire, the word is contradicting.
Hire is something which you pay for, and
free hire,
but free hire means free lending, it
should have been, but free hire.
But
may Allah give Jazaak Allah Khair to the
Muslim, he tried his best, but didn't do
a good job.
Now, because he didn't do a good job,
may Allah reward him for that.
He tried. We thought, now,
if he's not doing a good job, let us
start an organization,
and we named it Islamic Research
Foundation.
Main purpose was lending video cassettes
free
with a deposit.
Then we thought, "Let's have
a question-answer session." So one of my
friends,
who was quite
good
also in the field of dawa,
I told him, "Fine, you're good in dawa.
Why not
you take sessions? The organization will
support you." First time he went in
front of about 25 engineering students
in organization,
when he went to reply,
he got cold feet.
What to do?
Then Allah sent me, me being a
stammerer, I went in front of that
audience and started replying.
And by Allah's
mercy, grace, and help,
while replying, I did not stammer.
I was shocked. I stammered.
And I realized that when I used to speak
to the Christian missionaries,
there was no stammering. Otherwise, when
I spoke to the Muslims, I used to
stammer a lot.
So it was like a miracle, while speaking
to Muslims, I'm stammering, while doing
dawa, I'm not stammering.
Coming back to when I was in college,
even while giving the viva voce,
in school, in public speaking, when I
was giving speech, I used to get PF. PF
means pass fail.
Pass fail means actually fail, but
because they had mercy, bichara, poor
man, stammerer, let's not fail him. So I
used to get PF.
I was in St. Peter's school.
It was ICSE school.
The examination used to take place from
London.
PF, out of
pity.
Not mercy, pity.
And poor man, stammerer, let's not fail
him, PF.
When I used to dawa, when I started
after meeting Sheikh Deedat in the
medical college, my friend used to say,
"You are doing dawa with your teachers?"
And in medical college, 50% marks are
viva voce, orals.
In theory, if you fail, you can recheck
your paper and pass. But if a teacher
fails you in orals, there's no
rechecking of orals. And 50% of the
marks in medical
college, for most of the subjects, is
viva voce, orals, which, if they fail,
you can do nothing about it.
My friends used to say,
"You're doing dawa with your teachers?
You're crazy. They'll fail you."
I used to think,
"If they fail me,
maybe I'll get one more year to do dawa
with them."
If my teacher fails me, alhamdulillah,
Allah is giving me one more year to do
dawa with them. With this bent of mind,
with this optimistic view,
that if they fail me, alhamdulillah,
I'll get one more year to do dawa.
I entered into the field
of
dawa.
And alhamdulillah, summa alhamdulillah,
as I told you, I changed my style
from that soft to fiery, and I got
results.
And I saw people liked it, and
alhamdulillah,
the first time when I went
on the stage in a small gathering, it
was not by choice, it was by compulsion.
Organization, no, he got cold feet. What
to do? I went.
And I realized that it clicked.
So once a week, we had the session.
My friend told me, "You did good, you
only go." I said, "Baba, you are
supposed to go, not me. I'm supposed to
support you."
But alhamdulillah,
it went on, and
I remember the first lecture I gave, a
prepared speech
in my life,
>> [snorts]
>> with an organization, a small room of
only 25 square meters,
but had about more than 100 people. How
they sat, don't ask me. One on top of
the other.
And I did not know what is a lecture or
what is not a lecture.
No experience.
Okay, lecture should be 45 minutes.
I memorized,
and I gave it.
It went on for more than 3 hours. The
longest lecture I ever gave in my life.
The first lecture in my life was the
longest lecture of my life.
No experience whatsoever.
3 hours without notes, is the Quran
God's word?
More than 2 and 1/2 hours, then
question-answer session was another
30 minutes, so it was totally about 3
and 1/2 hours, you know, 2 hours
50 minutes lecture.
Imagine, first lecture of my life,
ever speaking,
a prepared speech,
thinking it would be 45 minutes,
went on for about
2 hours 45 minutes,
and
alhamdulillah,
without notes, 2 hours 45 minutes,
first lecture,
alhamdulillah, and from that time,
Allah's help and mercy was there before,
was there that time, and it continues
till today. And I pray to Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala, may it continue till the end
of my life.
Inshallah.
Then I asked my mother,
"Would you like me to become like Sheikh
Deedat or Dr. Chris Barnard?"
She said, "I can sacrifice a thousand
Dr. Chris Bernard for one Sheikh Deedat.
We'll discuss more about it when we
discuss setting up an organization.
But this is the introduction
that how did we come into this training
program?
And the first two times I met Sheikh
Deedat was in Bombay in India.
First time he came for a visit of one
day, we hosted him. Second time he came,
he spent about more than 10 days and we
were the host and we were with him
always
day and night. Before he got up, we were
there waiting for him. Till the time he
slept, we were with him.
And then every few months, I met him
either in South Africa or Saudi Arabia.
And alhamdulillah, I met him several
times.
Sometimes I stayed in his house many a
time
for a few days, for a week, met outside.
And he was inspiration though
I have not been formally trained by
Sheikh Deedat. I have not attended any
of his dawah training per se.
And the first lecture I gave was 1992.
Is the Quran God's word?
And that is the lecture I sent to Sheikh
Deedat.
And he was very happy.
That was the same lecture.
And then I thought that now I have
thought of becoming a da'ee, khalas.
There was a time when I had a feeling
that alhamdulillah, Allah has given that
power. I was very well known for
debating.
That like it is good in debating, but I
have to debate on things which are not
beneficial. You tell any topic you give,
I could debate.
So, the skill that Allah has given me, I
started using for the cause of Islam,
for the spread.
And we found the success, alhamdulillah.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
>> [singing]
Allah.